eight months after winning the title the
Rams are nowhere to be found and now
Carrie Underwood
[Applause]
oh what happened I went into the
bathroom to Zach yak and there was a
tiger in there what it's just who day
look away if you've seen one hangover
you've seen them all
[Music]
has anyone seen Allen Robinson I think
you saved him from Bears last night how
long have we been out and whose records
are these we need to get back into
contention before it's too late
I'll catch up with you later
found Allen that's Cooper cup you're
looking for a different receiver I have
other receivers how much could possibly
happen during one party them picks you
guys lost to something called Cooper
rush you did first y'all I think I know
how to fix this
I want to go for two you have 19 coach
don't worry guys I found a few easy
games where is the last place anyone
would expect to find Alan what the hell
man is
[Music]
I tend to think of myself as a one-man
Zach pack and then we drafted burrow and
there were two of us in the Zac pack
um and and then we lost to y'all in that
big old game we were like stop shooting
coach it's played out